[Music]
so dimension reduction uh you know we
already talked about how data points how
data or high dimensional points and the
examples we saw the web for instance
trees in the billions or many times
it'll at least a thousand so it's very
high of course we saw that geometry
looks different and all that but in any
case efficiency wise
it'll be nice not to have to deal with
such high dimensionality right so it
will be nice if we can reduce the number
of dimensions but of course without
changing the problem so in just reducing
the number of dimensions we shouldn't
lose properties right so we'd like to do
that there are two main methods of
dimensional reduction so one is random
projection so let me difficult to
represent very high dimensions on the
board right random projection just means
that I can show you two dimensional
points right there are points in two
space that are your data points and you
project onto a line orthogonal
projection and so on right now if you
project two to one dimension there will
be lot of problems for example you will
have potentially two points which are on
top of each other so their distance in
the projection is zero is much much less
than the distance of stairs now because
you're reducing dimension you expect the
demand distance to go down we'll see how
much by a certain factor but I don't
want it to become zero or I don't want
it to become really bad compared to that
factor so that's one issue so we want
random projections which are oblivious
to data in this case it'll be they won't
care about data is just random but we
don't want to lose all properties so
preserve some properties and the
properties depend on the problem but for
a first cut distances so you want at
least not to lose track of what the
distance between every pair of points is
so you don't want two points like that
to fall on top of each other it so this
lecture we will see in detail how to do
how to do this I mean it's just going to
say actually that you pick a random
projection pick this line at random and
then things will behave nicely we have
to prove that will prove that but so I
want to go over the sort of gentle idea
first before we start proving in general
what will happen with random projections
is that you preserve lengths to factors
which are 1 plus or minus Epsilon right
so the length in the projection will be
within a very very epsilon of the length
over on top now unfortunately as epsilon
falls the dimension is you need to
project to is going to grow we'll see
how much but I'll just write this down
the projection dimension is order 1 over
epsilon squared so if you want lo either
you need to project to a very large
number of dimensions right so if you
want really low error the dimension you
thing two is going to be so large that
it's not that useful remember we wanted
it to be computationally useful so that
won't happen with random projections so
random projections are good because you
don't have to process the data you can
quickly get it just as random just a
random image generator but they are not
good enough if you want error which is
less than little or one and you do want
there a lesson a loved one for a lot of
problems we'll see that not today but
we'll see that in general so random
projections are used too extensively in
theory because of a now I forgot to
stressed it but with random projections
will prove that every pair of lengths is
preserved so with high probability with
no exception every pair of the interest
preserve there is a probability of
failure that the lengths are not
preserved there is a small chance that a
random line will put two points one on
top of each other right as you can
imagine the chance is very low okay
there is a chance but what this is
saying by every is that with 99.9%
probability we can make sure that with
no exception every pair of points is
close okay now that's nice - in theory
we use it a lot but there will be
another set of projections there are
globally essentially two general methods
of projecting to reduce dimension one is
random projection the other one is
principal component analysis which also
will seen coming lectures there are
different properties projection length
behaves very well much better than the
epsilon error okay but only then
averaged over data so it's not true that
every pair of points the distance is
opposite it is true that on average the
distances are preserved very well so
some pairs may behave badly theoretical
use is a little restricted because of
this fact that it is not true for every
pair but it is used in stochastic
mixture models which likely at the end
of this lecture will already see a
mixture model and they'll come back
we'll come back to them later right
but PCA is very used very widely used in
fact for certain problems like nearest
neighbor
search which you will see PC is more
commonly used in practice than random
projections and random projections are
more commonly used in theory than PCA
okay
so PC is not today it's random
projections today okay so most of the
lecture will be on random projections
and then at the end of the lecture I'll
start on Gaussian mixture models which
will continue also when we do PCA okay
good so here's some motivation for the
kind of problems we can solve with
dimensional reduction in particular with
random projection so if somebody said in
fact a huge bulk I don't know what the
percentage is huge bulk of machine
learning and practical computation is
precisely this problem of nearest
neighbors such what is the problem the
problem is the following
you're first given a database of end
points in Rd and it's very large D is
also larger right you're given these
points you're allowed to pre-process
taking a lot of time taking polynomial
time in N and D okay thank you
dense clade any amount of time right you
do the pre-processing and then once
you've done it then queries come along a
query is also a point in Rd and ideally
want to find the nearest database point
to the query point but very quickly
it's sub linear time the data is
endpoints in D space so it's length is
nd so you want to do it little over nd
often in poly log time let's sit back
and think about this how about if D
equals 1 suppose I gave you points on
the real line right and then whenever a
new point comes I must very quickly find
it's near this point what do you know
how to do that I'm allowed to
pre-process what is the pre-processing
one might do for points on the line or
in one dimension sorry sort exactly
right once you sort the points then by
binary search a new point in logarithmic
time you can tell the nearest point
right and you should think a little bit
you can do this in fixed
in two dimensions for instance you can
also do this I won't go with that but
you so that's that's the kind of thing
we are looking for sort or do something
takes n log n time fine and then at the
end of it in a log in time you're able
to tell what is the nearest point we can
settle for approximate nearest Inn in
practice so we'll see that projecting
the database points into a random poly
logarithmic dimensional space is a good
solution we'll see that we have to show
you that at query time what we do is we
also project the query point down to
that space and measure distances so the
data points where here we have already
done this but this projection getting
these is pre-processing and query point
comes along that's a query point then we
project that and see its nearest point
there in the projection we don't bother
otherwise it's not quite that simple but
let's we can think of it that way
conceptually okay another example a
completely different example where
dimensional reduction is useful and I'm
going to give you there are lots of
examples I'm going to give you only two
linear regression what's called the
overdetermined case that's the following
you have a matrix a you want to ideally
you want to solve the equations ax equal
to B if there may not be a solution so
you want to minimize you want to find an
X so that ax minus B is minimized over
determined means a looks like this and X
is small dimensional you want it to be
approximately equal to B B is also
taller than right so this is interesting
in the case when really is much taller
than it is wide in as much larger than D
let's call over determine undetermined
if it's the other way so here is the
thought you take a random projection of
both sides you must hit both sides so I
can draw the picture better you have a
matrix P
which looks like this this dimension is
and that's n by D right this dimension
is n I call this well call this K so and
then you solve the projected problem now
it's a much nicer problem because this
is only a K by D matrix now I won't
prove this to you but to prove that a
solution to this is a good solution to
the top you have to do two things right
you have to prove that for every X here
okay this thing is a correct
representation with an error of the
length of this so length of a X minus P
for every X is roughly equal to the
length of P ax minus P P that's
non-trivial why is it non-trivial
because how many X's so you could try to
do that by Union bound I say for every X
this length and this length are closed
for one X right with a certain
probability so there's a probability of
failure for one X okay but you have how
many X's here the infinitely many X's
you don't know what X is going to be the
solution right
you have infinitely many X's so it's
difficult to just apply the Union bound
it can be done again I'm not going to do
this in detail but random projections
can be used to solve this there are many
other examples and I'm going to show you
at the end some clustering example
k-means clustering how you can cluster
in the projection and that's enough to
get an approximate solution up on top
and we'll discuss this later ok so the
order of business is now I'm going to
present the random projection theorem
and proof and then we'll go back and
discuss these applications so I want so
basically I want what's called a length
preserving projection so or you can call
it distance preserving will see that
they are the same relief
so we want a random length preserving
linear projection from Big D dimensional
space to K dimensional space case much
smaller okay we want those linear so I
want a matrix P it's a linear
transformation
I want a matrix P so that for every
vector V in D space the probability that
the length of P V is within relative
area epsilon of the length of V right 1
plus or minus epsilon wants to be 1
minus Delta or higher so the probability
of failure wants to be less than or
equal to Delta okay
a few observations before we prove this
here I put the quantifier for all
outside the probability right so this
says for every V probability is this
high right so let's understand that
that's important what if I place the
quantified inside so what if instead I
say that the probability for all we is
that a nice tape let's see if that
statement makes sense so would that be
possible
that's a stronger statement right this
statement is for 1 V at a time the
probabilities failure is small it says
for each we at a time but for every one
of them but one at a time this says for
every one simultaneously this is true so
is that possible that we can make the
strongest statement I didn't make it but
can be why
okay but any other answers I mean yeah
so we cannot do that because see
basically we are sitting in D dimensions
these vectors are in D dimensions where
D degrees of freedom
there's no way in general I can reduce
the degrees of freedom and keep anything
sensible right because because there D
vectors so null space is in fact one way
to see it so if if K is less than D
there is a nonzero be in a null space of
V null space of P P is K by D right in D
space there's always some vector that P
makes zero and then if you have that
vector you get a zero here you get a non
zero there right so one nice thing to
remember is zero is never within
relative error of anything nonzero right
never right so you can't so I can't put
the quantified inside I can only do it
once for one vector at a time
the original projection that was used to
prove this theorem it's called the
Johnson Lyndon theorem they use the
following their projected to a random K
dimensional subspace in terms of
matrices there P was so I they wanted to
project to a random K dimensional
subspace P had rows which are a basis
just like a linear algebra basis of that
subspace which means they were also
normal vectors are orthonormal
as you recall if the length is one and
they are mutually orthogonal so that was
their P the difficulty page paper was
very long this 50 pages the difficulty
was first how do you pick such a matrix
there's dependence between the rows
right I picked the first row the second
row cannot be independent necessarily I
must make sure the dot product is 0 I
must make sure of strict orthogonality
and that turns out to involve a very
complicated argument both for general
well for generation is complicated but
to prove lengths preserving it's very
complicated because of the dependence so
we won't do that we are going to do
something slightly different where the
vectors are not orthogonal but still the
whole thing works we pick K vectors
remember
case the number of rows of P this thing
right I'm gonna pick K vectors you want
through okay I'm going to make each of
them vertical Gaussian means they're all
variance covariance matrix identity just
one more time let's recap this what this
notation means we introduced that last
time I want to recap that so the
variance covariance matrix of a random
vector u so each of these uses a random
vector so if you have a random vector in
D space its variance Cohen's matrix is
just ith entry is a moment of inertia
right is the expectation of the ith
component times the date except we won't
want to make sure that means are zero
maybe men are already bees they're also
just subtract out two things now in eCos
identity means that different
coordinates are not correlated so
independent coordinates just means that
right so just so we can do so the
projection is going to be given by so I
want to project the vector X right its
projection is just the dot product with
these vectors okay that's what I'm going
to do if you're projecting space has an
orthonormal basis I would just take the
dot product with that that would be
exactly for the orthogonal projection
right this is not right these news are
not necessarily orthogonal so it's not
an orthogonal projection but it's going
to be fine for us that we still will get
length preserving property okay so it's
very simple I pick a Gaussian
independent vectors and just take dot
products with them so I get here a
vector with K components right instead
of D components okay well prove that for
each vector V the length of F of V is
not exactly 1 plus epsilon 1 plus or
minus epsilon times length of V there's
a root K factor we'll think about why
the root K factor before we do that let
me just ask you let's figure out what
the expected value of V dot u v is a
fixed vector use random right the
expectation of
back to you what the expectation of VR V
dot u 1 squared is or at least not per
pound
ok so any sort of thoughts about what
they what the expectation of e dot u1
squared might be what the dot product
squared might be or how we might compute
it so what do you think the random
variable V dot u one looks like you was
random these fixed remember it what does
the random variable just a dot product
look like sorry
Gaussian yeah it is Gaussian right will
because it's actually the sum of some
Gaussian it's about some of you depend
go siient so it's the Gaussian so that's
what makes this very simple the argument
compared to in or taking orthonormal
vectors so V dot u 1 is just a sum of is
this dot product right so sum over all J
of this the u 1j the components of you
are independent because there's normal
zero identity right the components of
you are independent so this thing is the
sum of V is not random we use a fixed
quantity so there's a sum of D
independent Gaussian and if you add up
gaussians the means and variance just
add up for whether they're independent
right the variance be careful
so V dot u 1 is distributed so the
variance of this component alone is V J
squared right the variance of this is 1
the valence of that is V J squared so
the V da squares add up to the length of
V squared so you get a normal this real
valued random variable now it's real
number is normal zero V squared
distribution right so with hyper so with
high probability this is less than C V
this is just a constant times there's a
number of standard deviations so there's
a normal random variable it doesn't
exceed more than C standard deviations
so this quantity is much smaller than if
we and you wear or collinear if they're
collinear you would get that much but
you get a factor rutile
this I claim should be reminiscent of
something we proved already and that'll
be nice to remember so we proved such a
thing for uniform random from a sphere
in D dimension so this is our D the big
space if I pick if I have a fixed vector
V and I pick a random you we prove that
you unit length in this case my you here
is not necessarily unit length it's of
length D so there's some scaling but
here unit length we saw that V dot u
will be less than or equal to 1 over
root T C over routine but that's equal
to V times u over routine because V and
your unit vectors in that case so I want
to write this down which I should have
written on the slides but it's worth
remembering I want to write this down
carefully so if we have two vectors V u
in our D which are independent then the
dark product is less than or equal to C
over root T times the product of the
lengths product of the lengths is
collinear right dot product is 1 over
root D times that this was our equator
theorem for for spheres we we here all
gift for gaussians which is easier but
it's true for most many distributions so
this is if you will equated
okay dot product is roughly 1 over root
D times what it would be for collinear
ok so that's true
ok now I'm ready to state the random
projection theorem I'm gonna stay two
theorems and then we'll prove that the
proof will not be very difficult
actually not much longer than that taken
of them so f is the same as we had I
take K Gaussian vectors and take dot
products there's a absolute constant C
such that for epsilon not too big
Absalon between 0 & 1 we have the
following thing
again the for all is outside for every
individual vector in our D everyone no
exceptions ok you take the length of F
of a the K vector minus root K times V I
forgot to answer the question why root K
but sorry let me just do that before we
go so sorry excuse me
so this expectation is constant right we
saw that if V is length 1 this
expectation is sorry this expectation of
the square of this is one constant okay
it's the length of V squared
but if V is length 1 this is constant
but I'm adding up K components so I'll
get K for the length squared of F and
root K for the square root so that's why
the root K comes up yes because I had K
Kapoor okay the probability that there
is a relative error so it's supposed to
be that the expectation is that well
it's not quite the expectation
expectation of the square is the square
of it that's all we proved and the
probability that the relative error as
more than epsilon falls off as e to the
minus very importantly K in the exponent
epsilon squared I'm going to abbreviate
for for for the future this statement
here as the length of F of V is within
epsilon error relative error of this
right that just means that I mean it
means Oh
means the opposite excuse me sorry
deafness means the opposite of that this
means that it's within relative error
but this is saying it's not so that
scenario right where the probability is
taken over random draws of the vector
you used to construct that other words V
is not involved in the probability right
and then a second thing which is in fact
a little more useful on the lines of
this picture that the lengths are
preserved it says for every epsilon on
any integer N and K greater than 3 over
C squared log n so very important that K
only grows is log n ok then I take these
end points then for every set of points
now the for all is inside the
probability right I I'm asserting that
the high probability all of them hold
all the links are preserved ok now then
actually all the distances are also
preserved I think this is stated on the
next slide so this is so this is the
distance between VI and VJ on the right
hand side on the left hand side is
actually the distance between F of VI
and F of VJ right which is the same as
therefore VI minus we get F is linear so
we'll see that that's useful
so everybody see ruff will come and
prove that why is this true based on
that that's actually simple right
any thoughts on why theorem 2 follows
rather easily from theorem 1 I claim and
we will write down a proof but let's
take a minute to see if we can guess
that
so one is tell them one saying theorem
on sayings for one vector the projection
is more or less length preserving what's
theorem two saying sorry convex not with
this one word I want here so we want how
many lengths to be preserved here we
want to N squared lengths to preserve
right so what might we do to get all N
squared to be preserved from knowing
that one is preserved Union did somebody
say Union Union bound right so I this
there's a lot of dependency it's not
true that the projections these things
are not independent of course right
because VI once you know some VI and
some other VJs and this is dependent
they're all the projections so it's just
a union bound so I have n squared things
to be preserved but luckily this thing
isn't the exponent so if you worked it
out once I put K equals some high
quantity times log n this becomes 1 over
N cubed or something probability of
failure for one point and there are N
squared points you just have to multiply
1 over N cubed times N squared that's
still small so we will actually write
down this proof ok let's prove the first
term right again it was going to be
quite simple before I prove it I think I
have some remarks including the ones
that I just made the claim is for every
D what if I just wanted the statement
for most three so let's think about that
so statement one suppose I wanted this
to be true not that not for every not
for every V but for most V it's a
simpler statement but is it useful ok so
maybe you can say if the if the data for
nearest neighbor search was random I
could just have a weaker theorem that
says it's true from
okay let's see if that's true so I
wanted a nearest neighbor search I
assumed that the data points they said
I'm given is random it's not the worst
case set can I then use a theorem that
says for most VM length preserving
actually you cannot even in case the
data is random let's think about why
that is
I always need that for every V it should
be preserved so if it is a random data
set right what does that mean that means
that most of that data set behaves well
but there might be exceptions even in
that data set and our nearest neighbor
search says I give you a query point you
must find absolutely the nearest
neighbor or close to the nearest I'm not
allowed to make errors so if the nearest
neighbor is an error point is an error
prone point I can get it completely
wrong I'm not allowed to do that so
nearest neighbor search in fact this is
true of any optimization problem if I
give you an optimization problem even a
random instance I want the optimal
solution or the approximate optimal
solution I don't want to say that you
can fail with some probability and give
me a nonsense right you cannot do that
so even though even if the data of a
random I would still need this for all
the so I cannot use the weaker statement
and the weakest aim is very simple to
prove suppose I have a random B and I
want to preserve length what would I do
something's much simpler than this so I
have a random D dimensional vector V
it's random and I want a projection
where the length sort of represents that
length not preserved exactly but maybe
with an effector what's a good simple
projection take the first component
right if if I if the vector was random
all components are roughly the same so
the first component should be 1 over
root D so so that that's not interesting
right but that's not also useful ok good
the advantage of linearity of F is
estimated simply
two points is some fixed factor 1 over
root K times the distance between their
projections right and that's because the
projection of the difference is just the
difference of the projection it's linear
so I could have just projected the
points and look at the difference right
you need linearity for that otherwise
you wouldn't big K being in the exponent
of the theorem is crucial so you get
logs because K is in the exponent there
are many other random projections known
now Gaussian is the simplest and easiest
to prove but for example the UI can be
taken as plus minus 1 random vectors
intuitively when these very large that's
like things behave like the normal right
central limit theorem behaved like the
normal but for smaller D also something
is true but that's more difficult to
prove here we don't do that we'll only
do it for Gaussian so but there are many
distributions now that for which random
projection theorem is wrong ok now the
proof we want to prove that that's true
with high probability scale both sides
we might as well assume that V is 1 so
if I scale the both side scale by the
same amount so I have no nice thing
about relative error is that I'm allowed
to scale both sides by any mark by any
factor but we want a relative error so
we can scale and so we assume without
loss of generality V is length 1 ok now
I just again this is a repeat something
I did earlier so the dot product is a
sum of independent random variables and
therefore the means and variances add up
so we get that this has distribution and
0 1 ok now you won these dot products in
or independent gaussians each is
distributed spherically right this
length of V squared is 1 so each dot
product is normal 0 1 they're
independent so the this is a
k-dimensional identity matrix F of e is
a K vector right so the K vector is
distributed exactly like that and we
apply the gaussian analyst theorem we
proved last time the gaussian analyst
serum told us
that that if you have a if you pick
points from independent Gaussian scape
points in this case the length will be
about root K because I picked K points
each of Gaussian normal 0 1 root K the
probability that soft by mod and beta is
e to the minus beta square times C only
valid for beta small enough only valid
for be to smaller a root K so this you
have to refer back to the Gaussian
annulus theorem we proved so this that's
not valid we didn't prove it for epsilon
greater than 1 but luckily we only need
3 epsilon less than 1 so all results
about these concentration results the
large deviations are always difficult so
if you want a deviation greater than a
certain amount it doesn't behave like a
Gaussian quite often but these kinds of
deviations we have behaves like Gaussian
which means I have a Beatrice Quade in
the exponent right beta square after
after while large deviations together e
to the minus beta we saw that for coin
tosses last time right so so we get this
so the probability is e to the minus K
epsilon square so beta escapes one so
that's that's the first thing we do have
to use the gaussian less time to prove
that which we proved already okay
theorem tools as I said Union bound so
we have N squared pairs of points
probability a failure for each Z to the
minus CK epsilon squared so with this K
if I put a log in there over epsilon
squared e to the minus C log n I can
make the 1 over N cubed or 1 over N
squared ok so it's important as they
said exponential in K so that K only
goes logarithmic so now I want to show
you a couple of slides of applications
so here let's so be prepared to answer
some questions let's see how that goes
so k-means clustering here's the problem
I'll draw a picture on the board given n
points in Rd you have to partition into
K parts so as to minimize the sum of
squared distances to the cluster Center
of each part so if I had I shown you
some pictures I guess so now I want to
partition em into five parts let's say
so I drew it so that there's a natural
set of five parts okay these are the
five clusters I partition the set of
points into five five sets after I do
that and I I put down maybe one more
point will be nice to see so I put down
some clusters Center for each cluster
allowed to choose any cluster Center and
then I take the distances square them
and add
and I want to minimize that it's not
difficult to see that the best choice of
center once I give you the clustering is
just a mean of the cluster right that's
only true for distance squid so even on
the line you can convince yourself I
give you a bunch of points I want a
point mule so that sum over X minus mu
squid is minimum and that happens
exactly at one point and Musa average of
all the X's it's only true if it means
Center distance squared actually there's
going to be other properties that are
only true for distance squared which are
not true for other metrics to see that
so that's true okay so here is a
question so this we are going to spend a
few minutes thinking about is an
important question so is the following
obvious so I want to divide this up into
K parts right I know that if I project
to some number of dimensions randomly as
we just saw in the theorem okay all
distances are preserved to 1 plus or
minus Epsilon
therefore why don't I just project and
then cluster in the projection after all
all the distances are preserved so that
should give me near optimal answer
within 1 plus or minus Epsilon so is
this true is this a proof let's think
about this so can I use the theorem to
argue that since the distances are
preserved I might as well project down
and cluster so the thing to think about
is how I prove theorem 2 from theorem 1
sorry
the Epsilon's might add up so something
like that but add up what Epsilon's will
add up hey it's it's a fair thing that
something adds up yes so actually the
reason I put the question is is false
false okay it's I can't I can't disprove
it but this is this this is not a proof
and you cannot carry out of proof on
these lines it is true the distances are
preserved we prove that okay is it
tricky question so let's see that so how
many distances need to be preserved this
is the importantly what theorem - we
only had N squared distances to be
preserved crudely how many possible
cluster centers could there be well
every subset could be a potential
cluster and there are 2 to the N subsets
each of them gives you a point which is
a mean and each such point is a possible
cluster Center right cannot rule it out
we cannot rule out which clusters will
be formed okay therefore if I want this
argument to be made rigorous I've got to
take distances from each possible
cluster Center to each data point so to
retain cluster centers so there are 2 to
the N events and I have to add up the
failure probabilities that's very bad
then you'll see that K has to be very
large
everybody see at least the argument why
the proof is fallacious right so this
proof is not true this is false but for
K means there's an easy fix which
doesn't apply to other criteria luckily
for any end points one can prove that
the sum of squared distances to the mean
yes is a set of points re is the average
sum of pairwise distances among all of
us so let me just draw that
I should prove that I should have proved
that on the slide I'm going to write
down a proof on the board I so we have a
set s of points and this is asserting
there are n points
this is asserting that some of X
belonging to s X minus X bar squared is
1 over s times sum over all X Y
belonging to s it's only true for
squares yeah may I make it this wrong it
might be as minus 1 I so this is not a
very difficult proof may be if I run out
of things to say at the end of the
lecture we'll prove that you can try to
produce very simple so for only this is
only truth its squared if I didn't have
a square there it's not true okay in
general so only with the square so there
are a lot of nice things that happen
with a square and this is one of the
nice things actually there are two nice
things that happen with a square on this
slide this is only true for square and
this is only true for square so now can
I make this assertion now can I make a
projection and what what has changed
after I told you this
how many distances do I does the
projection have to preserve now Africa
told you this so before I told you this
I was worried that totally in distance
is actually preserved right yeah it's
only and it's only an squared because
it's enough to preserve distances
between all pairs of points once I tell
you the distance between every pair of
points then the value of every
clustering is fixed that's what this is
saying right and therefore if I preserve
those distances I'm in good shape okay
so for k-means projections do work so
you should think about okay that's I
said there already you should think
about another creative many criteria
that are used another criterion is
comedian where you want to minimize the
sum of distances with no square sum of
distances to cluster centers then this
argument is not correct it does not work
right so there is a way to project to
get within a factor of two for comedian
but 1 plus Epsilon no k-means we lucked
out
okay so I this is now going to a
different topic gaussian mixtures which
is in that chapter
but the we will prove this perhaps later
it's also a clustering problem we we
won't actually have special lectures
just on clustering but this Gaussian
mixtures I want to do which has to do
with clustering will see that twice
today will say Gaussian mixtures and
then when we do SVD we'll see a better
algorithm now any questions or any
predictions before we go on to Gaussian
mixture
no because because we it's got to be
exact right because we want to all give
the optimal solution here is a Nierop
optimal solution up on top if we get an
upper bound that's going to say that the
cost in the projection is at most the
Causton in there right but it might be
spurious ly much smaller for something
that's very costly here and that might
be optimal here and I get the wrong
answer there's actually a good question
so I think we should go over this
argument that so if every distance is
preserved then the optimal answer is the
same right but the argument for that has
to go both ways first I have to say
forget an optimal thing here that's less
than or equal to everybody else
therefore also on top it's less than or
equal to so an optimal here is very good
there but also I have to argue an
optimal there is very good here so as a
good exercise to if I tell you all
distances are exactly preserved I have
two problems with end points each the
distances are exactly the same I get the
same optimal solution I mean that seems
trivial but when they are approximate
you have to some work to do
ah okay good point I should have done
that okay
so random projections do not preserve
angles they preserve lengths they do not
preserve angles that's a good point to
make okay good so if I to vectors U and
V I have a random P random projection P
then it's not true that the angle
between angle between PU and P V is not
equal to in any scaled way the angle
between U and B right so angles are not
preserved by random projections
neither or dot products
preserve means to relative error
okay so let's see white dot products
aren't preserved that probably is not
that difficult right so what can happen
to dot products so dot products need not
be preserved by projection so you can
get the wrong answer when you project
distances are preserved okay so let's
say that I have two vectors U and V I
want to worry about the dot product I
can write the following this is a usual
trick to express dot products in terms
of length
so if I project PU squid is 1 plus or
minus epsilon you squid let's say so
then if I plug that in here I will get P
of U minus V squared length is 1 plus or
minus epsilon u minus V squared on the
right-hand side the errors add up so the
right hand side there is become epsilon
times u squared plus V squared if now my
dot product is very small if they're
orthogonal
for instance U and V the dot product is
0 in the projection there won't be
exactly although nearly orthogonal and
so you don't preserve relative error
right so that's the same as saying here
that if the error is so much its form
stated in the dot product so dot
products are not reserved and their
finals aren't because angles are just
the dot product divided by the product
of the lengths the denominator is
preserved the numerators not so they
won't be preserved so dot products are
difficult to do with random projections
whenever some problem involves only the
only distances you can do but not
otherwise
that probably is a good idea to put into
the lecture okay on to Gaussian mixture
is then right so a Gaussian mixture is a
probability density sorry yeah that's
right yeah
still adding distance this that's still
true but the number of distances that
need to be preserved seem to be
exponential actually there are some
other constructions called call sets
which are more complicated by which you
can do something but I wasn't going to
get into that but but but you you can't
do it's not true that pairwise so the
following is not necessarily true if I
told you there are two problems to two
sets of endpoints all pairwise distances
are the same
is it true that the K median clustering
will be the same I think the answer is
no I don't know an example I mean you
can try to construct the example so it's
not purely a function just of pairwise
distances the median problem yeah yeah
anything except squares this you can
give us an a factor of two there's more
difficult
okay
okay Gaussian mixtures is just a convex
combination of probability densities
with your gaussians again a picture so
this is one Gaussian density there might
be another one right so I can take half
of this density plus half of this what
it just means is that just add the
weighted combination of the densities
right so wait for WT there are K
densities the WTS are non-negative
adding up to one it's a convex
combination
it's just exponential density with I'm
talking about now standard spherical
gaussians now variance 1 mu T or the
means right so just like this picture
the muties or this and I'll add them up
the problem to do with Gaussian mixtures
is with samples from a mixture or given
to you so the the real problem is the
reverse problem it's not the problem of
taking the mixture and then generating
points but it's a problem of fitting a
mixture to data that's given so we are
given data which is x1 to xn their ID
draws from that probability density and
I'll tell ideally from here you have to
just find P of X and here's another way
to say that an equivalent thing I can do
to pick the samples so I want to begin
samples I for each sample I I pick a tea
a component of P mixture one particular
Gaussian and then I picked those
components that probabilistic or
proportional to the weights right w1 to
wk and then pick X I from that density
right you should convince yourself that
these two are the same the distribution
of x1 to xn will be the same or
distribution x1 will be the same as I
idea
I'm the learning problem we want to
solve or the model fitting problem she
will I give you samples X I don't tell
you which Gaussian was drawn from I of
course don't tell you the muties I don't
tell you the means right we want to find
the T for each I
that's a clustering problem once I find
that I can fit a single Gaussian to each
cluster so I erase that so in this
picture you'll get samples like this
this is real right
so I'll get only the points on the real
line in general in d dimensional space
and I tell you two clusters so the right
clustering would be this and this okay
drawn them very well but this and this
right then I take all these points and I
have to fit a single Gaussian to them in
the book actually we worked at our desk
and that's you should know how to do
that so if you have a collection of
things drawn from one Gaussian fitting
the Gaussian is easy you just take the
sample mean to be the mean of your
Gaussian and it's sample variance or the
sample variance covariance matrix in
general to be that of the Gaussian
that's the best fit so you can do that
but the problem of identifying the
clusters is not reveal is is the real
problem to solve and the solution I want
is I want to say the following for let's
pretend the number of clusters is
constant I like to solve the learning
problem if means of each pair of
gaussians are separated by ten standard
deviations so this is a mnemonic that
you hear all the time right means
separated by six standard deviations
let's say ten or any constant I want to
say that's enough for me to learn the
Gaussian this is not trivial in one
dimension it is but in D dimensions it
is not revealed so we like to prove of
course if you like to come up with a
learning algorithm and prove that it
works under this is under this condition
another way to say that is K may not be
constant the number of standard
deviations the means should be a part
should can
something in depending on K so in these
two in this case write whatever the
standard deviation is about this much
and you better be separated by a
constant times that if the Gaussian or
less separated if they move on each
other there's no way to figure out the
individual ones right so you can you
want to mention is easy to see that that
you need that many and that you can do
so we will see that in this lecture we
will see that distance based clustering
can do this only if the separation is d
to the 1/4 standard deviation so the
number of standard deviations the means
have to be a part has to grow with D for
us to do it based purely on distances
purely on distances means I take two
points and if they are close I put them
in one cluster if they are far I put
them in are in different clusters that's
all I'm allowed to do then you need a
much bigger separation than the best in
next after SVD based algorithms we'll be
able to do with the best possible
separation namely at number of standard
deviations which is constant we'll see
that when we do a sweetie sorry oh yeah
well okay so I will I will actually say
that in the band if you want to get
everybody right you need an extra root
login factor so this is getting most
things right in the end I'll say that if
you want to get every point right you
have to pay an extra root log in factor
this is only going to get most things
right so everybody see the problem so
mean separated by a few standard
deviations now why is that
difficult so that actually in D
dimensions this is one picture I saw
from the book so I didn't actually sit
and draw it so I guess it doesn't quite
illustrate things as well I draw a
better picture on the board maybe that's
bit
so we are sitting in D dimensions D
large okay and we have standard Gaussian
so we read the minus x squared over two
so standard deviations one each
direction how does the Gaussian look
like we already saw that right we saw
that the expected distance squared of
the point is of Rd not about is exactly
D we saw this already right there four
things will be a distance about root T
from the center so all the most of the
probability mass is here let's say I
have two gaussians with means separated
by a few standard deviation standard
deviations one right so and this is this
is routine think of T is very large as
root D as much much bigger than one so
the next Gaussian is centered here and
it looks like this and this picture
should tell you the problem right I've
given you two gaussians with mass is
concentrated in the two annular and I
have to tell them apart that's pretty
difficult they are not geometrically
completely separated so this you can
call this Sun and planets picture right
so the distance is enormous compared to
the separations okay that's a difficulty
in D dimensions so I guess I'm trying to
draw that there but I'm not sure we did
it I did a very good job there so this
is the picture that I want to focus on I
want to find separate the annulus now of
course if I draw a hyperplane here it is
true although the picture doesn't look
nice like that it is even if this was
hungry it is true that most points of
this Gaussian or on this side most
points of that Gaussian are on that side
you have to prove that but that's true
the picture doesn't look like the road
at all but it's true right
and if I give you a hundred root log and
every point is like that what's the
difficulty with this the difficulty with
this I don't know this hyperplane right
now if only I could project to the space
so if only I knew the center's and I was
able to project Otto Bernal to that so
in this case so one dimensional subspace
I project the orthogonal then the
gaussians well separated they look like
this in the protection against something
you have to prove so I have to find this
projection to be able to do this then I
will be home it turns out SVD this is a
nice 3d subspace SVD does that this is a
preview we won't see that told a few
lectures we will see that actually a
proof of that when we do SVT right now
we are focusing on figuring out if based
just on distances I can do something and
the answer is no in this case I cannot
do it to spherical gaussians with the
Unitarians in every direction if x and y
are independent samples from the first
gaussian then okay maybe I should draw
the picture again so X is one sample for
the first Gaussian it it's always near
annulus and Y is another sample that was
a picture actually that's the first
picture right so the picture looks like
that
and they are almost nearly orthogonal we
saw that we've seen a proof of that and
in this picture that indicates that this
is the distance between them because
they are almost all tonal each a
distance root P from the origin the
distance is square root of 2 times
square root of T if I now have so first
maybe I'll explain the picture let me do
the calculation now they have two
Gaussian separated by Delta I've drawn
Delta to be very large just to do the
calculation
the first point access picked from the
first gaussian point y is picked point y
is picked from the second gaussian let's
see the distance between them that
distance the vector is I go from X to
its center and I go from the center P to
Q and I go from Q to this now let's
pretend that this is 90 degrees this
angle also this is 90 degrees look like
90 degrees but it is 90 degrees right
why is it why is it almost 90 degrees so
I want to claim that angle X P Q an
angle P Q Y or both about 90 degrees
what theorem that we proved may tell us
that
we proved the theorem to that effect
right and that theorem is sort of the
theorem approved you sort of this
picture
and this picture says this vector and
this vector almost orthogonal and that's
because what this vector so what is the
name of that theorem so that was the
equator theorem right so this vector
they're independent so I might as well
have picked this vector first then when
I'm picking this vector that's a fixed
direction we made it a North Pole we
know that this vector lies close to the
equator which means more or less our
problem we saw that the angle is 1 over
root T it's cosine inverse of that angle
so this line p2q the centers are fixed
before we picked any points they are not
random so this is a fixed thing
therefore this is orthogonal to it
nearly okay and once I fix this and that
this is orthogonal nearly to both of
them this is to equators so X defines an
equator of the sphere and PQ defines
another equator in drawl that and Q wise
orthogonal to both of them so it's a sum
of squares so you get D for the square
here d for the square there to D and
Delta squared ok I've worked this out on
the next slide
that's the same that was a picture proof
this was a reveal proof if x and y are
two linearly independent or sorry not
linearly stochastically independent
samples from the first gaussian then I
want to do what I want to figure out
what X minus y squared is I expand it
right I get a squared Y squared minus 2
x dot y x squared is d plus or minus
this is the gaussian annulus theorem y
squared also Gaussian and let's say plus
or minus order root D means and it's at
most
absolute value order rooty add or
subtract 2x y is order routine ah why is
that so x and y are independent samples
from the same gaussian 0 1 so i want to
know what x dot y looks like what's the
distribution of x dot y I fix X right
and then Y is random so this is X JYJ
this is the sum of and so X is fixed y
is random Y is random normal 0 1 right
and again independent so on so forth you
add up the variances you get sum of 0 x
squared x squared is about d 0 again it
requires a little bit of proof to show
all this so x dot y is normal 0 d please
this variant so it's a it's about order
routine again you have to pin down more
regular C these calculations but that is
true if the two centers are Delta apart
and X and Z or respectively from the two
different gaussians then I get this was
the second picture in the last slide
this I expand the three terms here ok
again the cross terms are very small and
they run out of the slide anyway because
they're very small but the most of the
main terms or just sum of squares
they're orthogonal so this square plus
the screen so you get this and this or D
each so I get to D I think they're also
ran out of this right okay
yeah I've run out of this light so
so same is 2d plus a minus order root D
different is 2d plus Delta so this is
very flattering words if two points from
the same Gaussian or closer to each
other than two points from different
gaussians and that requires this that
requires this be always greater than
that the worst case of this is Delta
squared minus C root D and that must be
greater than the best case of this sorry
that's the 2d here to D plus D so then
you need greater than root T or Delta
greater than D to the one-fourth so once
Delta once the separation goes below D
to the one-fourth you cannot tell
distance wise in fact these these
calculations can be reversed the
converse is also true now this is for
one we didn't do the calculations quite
right there was a pair as the question
was right what do we do with all points
so if we put an extra root log in factor
because it's Gaussian e to the minus x
squared with the minus root log in so
extra root log in factor you get failure
probability for each distance goes down
as 1 over n cubed or something so it
works for all of them so what is this
model of the stories you need a very
large separation between this means more
than standard deviation number of
separations before you can tell the
Gaussian apart even two of them
spherical this can be generalized to any
number and can be generalized a lot of
work has been done I mean this is sort
of a active research a a lot of work has
been done and being done on learning
Gaussian mixture
so it looks like that was the last slide
so even though it's possible to the five
I could finish unless there are
questions so we could we could have some
discussion or questions if you Oh
otherwise we meet on Thursday next right
number one number two this is going
faster than I expected right so on
Thursday I'll already start there
sweetie chapter and because it's going
faster we will hopefully do at the end
massive data matrix computations using
sampling that's in a later chapter I
think Chapter seven or eight and in that
we will do also SVD and all that but
we'll do it with sampling
so the order business is one Thursday
will be start of SVD it'll probably run
for three lectures and then will branch
off into other things sorry yeah sorry
yes it's one sentence there there is a I
think that's right it dealt a root D
right I'm sorry it's not Delta Rudy no
it's only Delta so this has length Delta
this has length D length root e sorry
right the dot product is one root T off
to random vectors the dot product is
rooty factor less than being collinear
so if they had been collinear to ravine
Delta Rho T divided by root T is a delta
so Delta Squad should be greater than
Delta as well as Rudy and Dell is
greater than Delta it's a tribute
inequality so it's greater than true T
so I I guess I would write this down
more carefully and put it in the slides
but yeah so yeah I think you need only
yeah once you have the right projection
you can do it so maybe you're saying
information theoretically what yeah if
you're not worried about an efficient
algorithm then mean separated by a fixed
number of constant sound divisions is
enough so if you're worried about a
polynomial time algorithm though then
then it's not then it's enough still
with a 3d but not without HD yeah so I
guess that's a good distinction so
information theoretically it's enough
that the number of separation is a few
standard deviations large constantly the
first thing is that if the insert of
separation based on standard deviations
standard deviations are different in
different directions so I take the
maximum of all standard deviations of
all gaussians if I have that much
separation I can do it okay that that is
somewhat clever that's 20 years old
maybe in the 90s actually so so I think
yeah there was a paper of Santa burrows
and mine which we proved things like
that but then people worried about more
what's called the pancake problem which
is very nice so you have two gaussians
which are very long and skinny like that
so their standard deviations in this
direction is small but in every other
direction is huge and they are separated
by hundreds and deviations in that
direction but by no means this is by no
means hundred times the maximum sanity
can you tell them it turns out to be a
hard problem you can now we know how to
do it now for two standard two gaussians
I'm not sure we still know how to do it
for K gaussians for the pancake problem
so what standard is what the standard is
separation between means which is omega
of maximum then that's okay but ideally
you'd like the standard deviation the
direction joining the Centers and I give
you a hundred times that separation can
you do it that's not easy so it's
probably it's for instance not true that
if I do SVD I get this direction if I do
again this is looking up because we
haven't done it's really yet but if you
did SVD then we won't get this direction
right it's actually the least singular
value direction the techniques are
different yeah so in fact what you do
here is throw away the least singular
values and work your way up so something
different it's somewhat PCA related
somewhat relate to singular value
singular vectors but not quite directly
the eigen structure is still used okay
so if you if you want to know more about
any of these things you can ask me for
references and both random projections
Gaussian mixtures and so on or topics of
current interest interest rate